le pet commandes c'est une sorte de sa
tête pour entraîner les chiens il a
plusieurs fonctions le contrôle
d'aboiements l'entraînement une lampe de
poche et bien comme lampe de poche
peut-être mais comme système pour
entraîner les chiens moins sûr voici le
système pète comme end un tout nouveau
système qui corrige de mauvaises
habitudes instantanément répète quand
même émet des ultrasons
c'est son attaque des fréquences nous
n'entendons pas mais que les chiens eux
peuvent percevoir en appuyant sur le
bouton approprié du pet conad un son à
très haute fréquence est émis pour
interrompre les aboiements
instantanément le fabricant affirme même
que c'est ultra sons permettent de
dresser un chien à faire des choses
étonnantes
il suffit de mettre le signal vaut lui
pour lui apprendre les bonnes manières
constatez vous même les progrès
accomplis en si peu de temps nous avons
consulté deux éducateurs canins
pour eux c'est clair un son ne peut pas
dresser un chien aller chercher une
bière dans sa glacière ou les pantoufles
de grand mère
les suffit d'appuyer sur un seul bouton
pour faire taire tout enchaîné
incroyable vraiment nous avons voulu
bien trop au chenil de la spéciale la
société où la prévention de la cruauté
envers les écoutes évidence 5
fonctionnent pas aussi tic dans la peau
nous avons demandé un technicien de
mesurer les fréquences émises par le
fait quand même
surprise en mode contrôle des aboiements
des fréquences sont si élevés que les
chais des ententes à terme
idéal pour les chiots qui apprennent à
marcher correctement
vous pouvez maintenant gressier votre
chien comme un pro les deux ponts
auxquelles nous avons parlé n'y croit
pas et c'est un animal grands du temps
et les meilleures méthodes passent par
le renforcement positif
les récompenses une [ __ ] éteindra
votre télé mais ne dressera certainement
pas votre chien